men want to feel like they're respected
and needed and again because women are
hypergamous and you know you want to
look up and across to a guy so you have
to be able to look up at him like you
want to be with a giant right so how so
how hard is it for a successful race car
driver that uh host TV shows has her own
podcast done well in life to find a guy
like that
and a lot of these guys by the way
they're not necessarily looking for that
right they're so they're usually looking
for younger women like they don't really
care about about a woman's
accomplishments there's no guy that's
ever said again look at the degree on
her wall look at that that's cool that's
odd no no no the problem is is that it's
triggering like because it's not that
it's not that I can't respect this the
other him even if he makes less or is
less successful or whatever those things
are it's that he doesn't respect himself
in my company
well that's a big turnout for women
right I mean I think in general for men
that is the problem I don't think it's
I'm not right could that is that not
where do you live on the west coast huh
where do you live in the west coast
Scottsdale oh Arizona okay so I mean
that's that that's not I mean that's not
California right like you know there's
it's becoming California because they're
all coming here but right right right
okay so yeah but yeah I mean you're
gonna have more like sort of stronger
guys in a state like Arizona than you
will in a place like California but I
get it like it it's it's definitely hard
for women like I know a lot of women
like you right that are that are up
there they've done something with their
life they've they don't need a guy right
like their life is set everything is
good you know it's like you know if he
comes in my life and he looks good with
me when we go out sort of thing we have
a good time and that's awesome but
there's a lot of women in your position
where they end up settling and they end
up settling for like the best that they
can get sort of thing and even though
you know uh it happens and it goes that
you know that route they're they're
generally not happy is what I find right
and then they I mean if they don't need
the guy then they'll just let him go
right because they because they're
better alone than they are with somebody
that's an anchor in their life you know
we have anchors and sales in life
obviously and you know when our sales
filled with when they take you to an
export a call and you have you know
great time sort of thing and there's
anchors that hold you back and I think
women are fastidious when it comes to
um their level of tolerance for guys
they can't look up to that they don't
see as a giant that they
um don't want to you know they won't
respect sort of thing so it's it's going
to be difficult for somebody like you in
your position to find somebody that's of
that caliber and higher
um that will just say hey you know Dave
we'll see you later on after you host
that show tonight
yeah or is that or is not that caliber
but can respect it and not be triggered
or not feel insecure so okay I've taken
a lot of your time
what what advice would you have
you can give it for men or men and women
or separately what advice would you have
that
would help
the person be led into the right
relationship
well it's different advice again for men
and women that's fine then go ahead and
separate them out then
um
for women well I I'm going to describe
the kind of woman that I want I've
already kind of done this you know uh
throughout our conversation but for me
as a leader a guy that is competent
successful you know all those things
again I want a woman that's a compliment
to my life right like I want her to add
value I don't want to come you know and
deal with a disagreeable
uh you know woman that's gonna create
Havoc or potential difficulty in my life
invite chaos invite you know unnecessary
nuances sort of thing
um I don't want to deal with the unhappy
or The Unlucky you know what I mean so
you know for a woman like she needs to
be that gal that's that's the sort of
gal that I would look for but that's not
that's not what most women are today and
that's not what most women are are
hearing as far as influences like
the biggest influences out there like
who are they uh lizzo you know you're
beautiful at any size oh please uh Kim
Kardashian you know like she's a huge
icon out there you know I mean
feel bad for Kanye but Kanye you know he
hasn't got his head screwed on right
either you know you got guys like Will
Smith and Jada Pinkett Smith oh my God
the slap like dude you let your wife
sleep with your son's best friend and
then you aired it on TV in front of the
world right so
these sorts of things when I was a kid
are were unheard of but this is
normalizing in society today so you got
to get away from all of that nonsense
from all of that garbage and you know if
you're a woman you want to identify the
kind of guy that you want and then be
the woman that he wants to be with and
I'm telling you right now you know as a
guy that's at that level and I have a
lot of you know friends of my network
that are very successful entrepreneurs
they're eight nine figure guys you know
we do fun and cool stuff together uh
many of them are in long-term
relationships and to be honest with you
they're really not that interested in
other women right like they're fine
other women pose extra problems for them
unnecessary problems sort of thing so a
lot of these guys are already taken two
you know so that's the problem as well
so rather than spending your 20s
partying getting 17 degrees you know on
the wall I think that your best use of
your youth which is when you're most
valuable to men is to develop yourself
into that woman that that that guy that
you want to be with is if that's the guy
that you want to be with happens to be
you know what I mean if you want to get
degrees and climb the corporate ladder
and do all that stuff that's fine but
don't be surprised you know if you're 41
with three cats and you want to have a
family and no guy is interested in you
or you can't conceive because it's too
late sort of thing right like there's
like I'm almost 41 with two dogs well
men and women are on different time
scales right you know there's there's
there's medical Miracles today that
would that would still allow you to have
a family obviously I did freeze my eggs
when I was 33. okay so I mean like you
could still have children obviously
right yep but I mean if your goal right
now is if like is your goal a family
like what is your goal today boyfriend
family no I don't I don't it doesn't
really matter it doesn't really matter
Adventure yeah well see that's the thing
I mean you want to get clear on your
goals you know exactly what you do so if
your goal is to have a family to have
children
then you should be
explicit about only doing things that
lead towards that if your goal is
Adventure then why did you bother freeze
your eggs
security safety blanket safety net yeah
yeah just insurance
yeah so I think you need to get clear on
what your agenda and what your goals are
and really stick to that
and like again understand evolutionary
psychology and what men and women are
evolved to do and be in relationships
and how relationships do work and how
and what women respond to what men
respond to and if you want to get a good
response you know you have to feed that
you know sort of thing
all right if men could do one thing to
make themselves into the man
that is consistent and attracts the
right kind of
partner
girlfriend wife whatever that is what
would it be what would you recommend to
them
it's nothing else other than Chase
excellence in your life make something
out of yourself there's too many guys
today I feel I feel so just that I feel
I think that our two
it's probably the first time in the
podcast that I said it actually
um there's too many guys today
no no but you haven't said I feel that
much I've been listening to you you know
you started with I think but there's a
lot of guys today I think that are too
compliant because they've been told just
be yourself and just be yourself is the
worst advice I think guys can take just
be average no woman wants just average
even even the gal that's pregnant with
the two kids from the two different dads
who's 26 that just got right with God
after partying through her 20s even she
doesn't want average no no but yourself
is not average that's not the same thing
right be yourself is own who you are and
that will make that everyone is unique
and different and it's like the
interpretation you are then you can be
great right but the interpretation that
most men have today when it comes to
just be yourself is just be a nice guy
if you like playing video games that's
good enough if you like being 300 pounds
at five foot seven that's good enough
because you're just being yourself right
and this is what guys have been hearing
and that's not what women are attracted
to that's not what then they want to
have families with exactly
they haven't done the work so do the
work yeah all right rich thank you so
much that was very interesting I
appreciate your time I appreciate your
perspective and I'm gonna keep watching
you got it thanks for having me Danica I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out